we've covered upload speed hiccups for
large files but what about when it's
time to read on this episode of cloud
storage bytes you'll need your reading
glasses because we're talking large file
downloads we've all been there staring
at our watch wondering how much longer
it's gonna take for that large file to
move from cloud storage to the virtual
machine where computation occurs even if
it's only two minutes that's an eternity
as far as we're concerned especially
when we're paying for that computing
power during our download ouch when
looking at our options here we might
recall that gsutil saved the day for our
uploads but that doesn't seem to be the
case for our downloads we even found
that curl outperforms GSU till here but
why and just when we thought we had it
all figured out luckily I'm on the case
and as it turns out the default settings
for GS util don't work particularly well
with large file downloads this is
because these default settings are
designed to spread downloads across four
threads using one process we should be
able to improve the performance by
limiting the number of threads and
forcing the system to use multiple
processes instead for a quick recap
processes are instances of execution
while threads are individual executions
that run inside of a process we want
more processes but each focused on only
one task
so first up limiting the number of
threads to do this there's a
command-line option to specify the
thread count we'll go ahead and reduce
it to one with this small change we've
improved the performance but we're still
not at the level that curl is showing
when we're fetching through HTTP so next
up forcing multiple processes to do this
we're going to have a throwback moment
to a previous cloud storage bytes where
we discussed a parallel composite upload
now it's time for parallel or sliced
downloads which we can trigger by
telling GS util to use a certain number
of components so to recap decreasing the
number of threads and increasing the
number of components can work together
to dramatically improve your download
speed there's plenty more to come about
optimizing performance but that's for
another episode
if you want to know more about
downloading large files check out the
links in the description and as always
don't forget to subscribe give us a like
and tell us what you want to learn about
Google Cloud storage thanks for joining
us for this quick byte of cloud storage
see you next time
[Music]